yo what's up everybody it is precision
metallurgy with another Borderlands the
pre-sequel video now this video is not
going to be a legendary guide is not
going to be any any form of guide it is
going to be a video where I want to talk
about some of the stuff that I want to
talk about obviously from the title of
the video you have an idea where I'm
going to this so and also quick note
about the gameplay it's just going to be
gameplay it's just some game played me
killing bosses since I thought it was
appropriate and there's no Sentinel
fights
my last video was a Sentinel fight I
think you guys don't want to keep seeing
that on repeat so let's get into the
meat of the video now this video is
going to talk about why Borderlands the
pre-sequel isn't good now as a statement
board I do find Borland's OOP is equal
overall I'd say it's a good game I enjoy
I enjoy berlin's to I enjoyed this game
but there are flaws in it that I want to
mention and bring out these flaws are
highlighted significantly by the fact
that Borderlands 2 came out before and
it is very similar to Borland's 2 so you
can compare the how each game compact
matches up to each other so first things
first I want to talk about the well
actually yet first things first is going
to be the endgame the main thing I see
as a problem with Borland's the
pre-sequel
is its end game for a variety of reasons
now the story most people I think like
the story it's enjoyable overall some
people might not like it but I don't
think that that suffers as much the end
games where I think this game doesn't
hold up to its predecessor or where it
should address as a standalone game
since it gets boring now the end game of
Borland's appease equal basically
consists of farming a very limited pool
of bosses and using the grinder to get
legendaries now the the goal of the
borderlands games seems to be shoot
stuff get better gear and so the end
game would be get the best gear which
are the legendaries in most regards so
when getting the legendaries and when
trying to get the best gear is in
isn't where it should be that is a
significant part of the flaw of the game
now there are what a major point of why
the end game isn't good I'd say is a
it's cut it's boring and there's a lot
you can do there are a ton of bosses in
this game or characters you will that
are one-time accessible in a quest
that's it you see them in the quest if
you kill them they don't drop the
legendary either dashboard and all F or
all f4 or edit save files to play the
quest again since you're not getting the
legendary from that person any other way
that person will never be there again
and I do not think this is a good idea
I'm going to give you an example just of
a good amount of the unfarmed bulls
we have flame knuckle we have the ever
even more disgusting torque Brewster
Brewster the gigantic ice sugar ruff
meathead Drago bones rabbit Adams boomer
Bruce Power Suit noobs are Patton both
forms meg and tiny destroyer now all of
these drop Legendary's however every
single one of these Legendary's can be
gone a different way
whether it be like I'd say one or two of
those you there legendaries drop from
other people but otherwise gonna have to
use the grinder and the grinder has good
process where you go find you JIRA who's
a big Cragin and who drops the thingy
legendary rocket launcher very often and
it's farm him for two thingies get a
purple of what type of gun you want put
it in it gets your legendary if you
don't get it dashboard and reput in the
grinder and you'll have your legendary
now this really takes away from ID one
of the most core parts of Borderlands
which is finding the best way the
quickest way to kill a boss and get his
legendary and that is a huge part of the
game it is a really fun part of the game
well I get not part of this game but it
is a very important part at least in my
opinion of what Borderlands is and this
game takes takes it out it makes you
rely on the grinder and Ruggiero to get
your Legendary's now there are there are
a few of the good amount of legend areas
you can get without using a grinder at
all you can farm
the bosun for the cry of phobia Felicity
for the quasar the final the final rate
boss the Sentinel you can farm him for a
few Laden there's the long nail zx1 ah
the black hole and so there are some
other people like uh actually I don't
think I don't think the first boss
deadlift has a legendary Titan that's my
knowledge at least but there are there
are so many legendaries that you cannot
get without grinding meat it takes away
from a lot of the game so that that and
the fact that there is a very small pool
of bosses to farm from as I mentioned
those make the end game kind of tedious
so it's either far me or JIRA or farm
the veteran use a grinder or farm the
vending machines and both those do not
encapsulate what in what in my opinion
means to play means to play Borderlands
play the end game of Borland's also
another point that I do not like in this
game is there are so many carryover
legendaries I'm gonna read to you a
bunch of the carried over legendary so
apologize for giant lists but I I need
to make this point alright so we got the
Major Tom carryover shred of fire hammer
burster hammer buster - kaboom torrent
fates Hall Hellfire Mongol I think is
cryo phobia the bada-boom Nukem all the
lasers and the Oscars are new which is
very good i I do appreciate all those
new legendaries that are really cool the
88 frag them Logan's gun shooter rang
Maggie blowfly shoddy sledges shoddy the
Stryker the flak ur the viral marketer
is basically the conference call but in
corrosive form the pitchfork the school
masher the long nail no sorry I have a
list of all legendary another long nail
is not to my knowledge and I met again
actually one of the one or two of those
wrong but basically all of those are
carryover Legendary's which is just it
it's laziness that's what I like
laziness to me that the developers would
not put in new legendaries they will
just carry over so many legendary
and a good amount of those legendary
Zardoz renamed and reskin and a lot of
not reskin that much like they look
really close to the same so the I guess
that's three points the limit of bosses
well I guess again correlation and the
the limit of bosses with the grinding
and bought and/or JIRA farming because
bosses are behind quest walls prevents
just so much so much of the next that is
the core of the end game that's gone and
just the amazing amount of carried-over
legendaries from Borderlands 2 is just
the those two ish three things really
take away a lot from this game and I
think to six fix this I was a quick fix
make all any person who drops a
legendary make them farmable and add a
lot of new legendaries that is a lot of
work but that is what needs to be done
to make this a really good game standing
alone from Borderlands 2 we can't
piggyback off of Borderlands 2 and be
called a great game in its own right so
that's basically it for this video I
hope you guys guys have enjoyed this
small or shlong rants and I'll see ya
later peace out
you